hallo Clixoom hallo Alberto ja mein Name
ist juri und ich hätte drei kleine
Frauen an euch oder an Dich ja also
erste Frage wie seid ihr auf den Namen
Hamburger hänge gekommen ja zweite Frage
woher kann ich den Vater so gut also
diese Mädchen war Stimme
und dritte Frage was inspiriert sich so
an den Beatbox
wie also wie er findest du neue Beats
und ja
was liegt dir daran
Hamburger Hänger also ein Kollege von
mir hat mir damals was los hier Hänger
was los du Hänger hier Hänger aber
irgendwann einmal ein T-Shirt gemacht
und habe einfach das Hamburg Logo und
habe da Hamburger drauf geschrieben und
ich finde die Gegend fahren wirklich
jeder hat mich angeguckt egal jeder
gucken auf einmal gedacht äh ich
verkaufe die Chance einmal und dass das
Ganze patentieren und ja dann auf einmal
habe ich einfach nur ein Abspann an
meine Videos Hamburger Hänger dran
gehängt und dann sind wir die Hamburger
geworden also da bin ich schneller
reingerutscht als ich eigentlich dachte
ähm mein Vater warstimme kann ich weiß
es nicht als sie mich damals adoptiert
haben da konnte er sie auch schon und
hat mich schon als Kind immer damit
begeistert und er sagt auch er hat sie
als Kind gelernt also vielleicht kann
ich hier noch mal fragen ob er selber
noch meine Video Antwort auf dein Video
und ja wie ich beim Beatbox inspiriert
werde also es ist immer verschieden mal
bist du einfach gerade zu Hause und hast
einfach nur eine freakige Idee und setzt
sie um mal hörst du einfach nur ein Lied
was der begeil ist das ist halt wirklich
immer verschieden also da kann ich ich
kann nur sagen wenn du selber Beatbox
also wenn du irgendwas im Kopf hast
einfach versuchen dann wieder
runterzulegen und dann wird das schon